what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to
basically the only thing that i've ever
accomplished
um my college athletic career so
before i was maybe like a year or two
ago literally the only thing that
mattered to me
was college sports i loved sports only
thing i cared about
only thing i ever wanted to do but
people ask me all the time to see
footage of me playing so this is from my
volleyball senior night this is really
just for fun if anyone wanted to watch
me play
yeah so i don't know if anyone cares i
don't even care if this gets two views
like this
i've already skipped over the other
seniors but there was like
five of us
joined by her parents ted and judy's
childhood
this season she ranks third on the team
and kills while leading the team in
blocks
named tournament team at the midwest
invitational earlier this year
scotland has played in 41 career matches
and homes totals of
137 kills okay she was actually really
nice
but
that girl that girl was an inspiration
to me
she literally rode the bench for three
years to play one
i would have quit by that but she had a
good senior year honestly
my real name is hannah i know shock and
awe
but people call me by my middle names
my dad's so proud
i was ready to go
i was so mad at my mom she was late and
she didn't walk me out
i forgave her but i was so mad
so there you have it senior night all
the seniors really contributing mightily
which is pretty cool they all have done
an outstanding job here at elmer's
college and it's great that they
recognize the ladies here on the
final game of the regular season now
both of these two teams could
meet each other in the cciw tournament
over the weekend
in decatur millikin university will have
the number one seed
illinois wesleyan carthage and elmhurst
as i mentioned all battling for second
place
illinois wesleyan probably will get the
number two seed so
if elmhurst wins tonight they could get
the three seed
if they lose tonight they'll probably
get the four seed so either way
it'll probably be elmhurst and carthage
playing in one of the semi-final
cci guys funniest thing so i'm see i'm
i'm like
running over here i'm gonna just explain
this
my team did not know that i sang
so right now this is going to be the
first time half the people thought it
was a joke of me singing the national
anthem
again at millikin on friday the two
semis and the championship game will be
saturday
november 4th for the cci watch everyone
turn
this saturday now everybody on their
feet as we are going to play now our
national
okay you see them they're all shocked
i'm gonna i'm
kind of embarrassed this i didn't do
great but i did okay
i was so nervous
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god i was so nervous i remember
shaking because i had never said a
national anthem before i just said
effort it's my last game
[Music]
is
yeah everyone i'm telling you my team
was shook
ah i still get nervous this is three
years ago
that was like beautiful rendition of our
national anthem by hannah davis thank
you
thank you one of the seniors being
honored here tonight she can do it all
sing the national anthem
you're right i can sir i
can now the player introductions let's
listen into bruce hill
i always i wish i started this social
media [ __ ] in college it would have been
so much content
[Applause]
williams
[Applause]
nelson brown
oh my god okay
i really wish that we could just get
through to the start
have to win by two rally scoring system
your officials tonight the r1
christian kashizak the rtr-1
christian and the two line judges paula
mcaleese
and cinque robinson
so we are about ready to go here tonight
happy halloween by the way to all you
ghosts and goblins out there hopefully
you
enjoyed your trick-or-treaters and
everybody's safe at home and
tuned in blue jay volleyball while uh
counting your candy and putting a couple
in your mouth why not
right as i mentioned both of these two
teams with identical conference marks of
five and two
there's a three-way tie for second place
in the conference carthage
is also five and two milliken has
already wrapped up the conference
championship
going undefeated milliken is at one and
six carroll tonight
there's a block by illinois wesleyan so
it's gonna be
ali what are you doing of the titans as
the first set
gets underway here from r.a fagona hall
keira jackson a 5 8 sophomore this
film for the titans
from the back row up the middle it was
taylor zerlin
yeah take that wesleyan
point's gonna go to the blue jays to tie
the game up
at one
serving now is taylor nerchy one of the
seniors being honored here tonight
blocked by the titans and now wesley now
the attack and they're going to see
titans lead it now by the score of 2-1
take another look at it here
to the far side partially blocked by the
blue jays but it did go up this girl was
really good on the other team
i remember her yeah she's at that time
leads the team and aces was 33 and you
can see why there boy
she's got a wicked serve and there is a
kill
by tyler brown this isn't looking good
tyler brown a 5-8 junior outside hitter
went to normal west
high school and with authority
and the titans lead here in the first
set by a score of three to one
the push by ally rogers too much club on
that one and it's
four to one in the early going
take another look at it there too much
the head coach
julie hall in her 24th season as the
head coach of the blue jays
and that is a service ace take another
look at it here the high
toss and that one just in says the line
judge so it is now
five to one
34th ace of the season for block
and there's one dean getting the kill
that's my best friend no she was
actually really good
and that kind of stops the bleeding it
was it was so fun because my senior
years like me and my best friend were
the ones on the team and we literally
had so much fun nelson brown in her 22nd
year
as the head coach so two veteran coaches
and they've done a great job with their
respective programs here
five to two in favor of the titans if
you've just logged on
and there's a service error by elmer's
celine what are you doing
we are just getting underway here okay
guys i'm in next
i just played five leading here
six to two and now the
libero reigning emery sophomore
that goes in front of the basketball far
side
the kill attempt by brown partially
blocked by the blue jays lundine
yeah she was so good she still
is but the right side hitter the senior
out of portage
central high school no i'm in
all right guys you mentioned earlier
drum roll please my athletic ability is
coming to play well the seniors really
have contributed mightily this season
and so that's a great thing to see
amy shriver defensive specialist
serving over here to the near side this
is shoot i'm sorry i messed up
illinois lane will get the point seven
to three
and now serving for the titans number
16.
caitlin meyer watch me i killed it
officer receive
jump serve knuckle ball serve going over
the net
kill attempt by zerlin
and illinois wesley encounters with the
kill tyler brown
getting the kill am i going to get set
oh but they're all calling a violation
against illinois wesleyan so it's going
to be 7-4
elmhurst trailing by three and serving
the dig in the kill attempt by rachel
berkman of illinois wesley
zurleen and now it's wesley now the
attack block going out of bounds and so
it'll be a point for the titans not
looking good for us
take another look at it here good effort
by the blue jays
they timed it nicely it just went out of
bounds
titans by four yeah yeah you see that
wesley now on the attack and that kill's
gonna begin by rachel burkman
the junior outside hitter
rachel with 263
kills coming into tonight that second
second leading kill person for wesley
the leader is tyler brown with 367
kills coming into tonight so they've got
a pretty
pretty good tandem that kill attempt
goes long by kylie block
and it is now nine to five as we take
another look at it here block
a little too strong to make it nine to
five
blue jay serving this is taylor zerlin
the freshman out of juliet catholic
a couple of freshmen in the starting
lineup for the blue jays
and they can't handle that one zerlin
and rachel
shooty of the starting lineup both
freshmen take another look at that
no this i remember this game being close
five in favor
of wesleyan
yeah yeah i'd kill it by hannah davis
i told you i'm athletic and hannah davis
263 kills right now she had 262 coming
into this one
so guys as a middle you play front row
and not back row
i could not pass so i had a wicked serve
but my passing skills
were subpar i don't know if i make this
or not kelly rogers
i'm just saying in general as far as the
team leaders
ten to six blue jays trailer yeah you
see that serve
yeah titans had problems with that one
so it's now
ten to seven so we take it down i want
him
to play ball just a little bit and it
lands
innocently on the titan side of the
court
and that one a little too strong so
wesleyan gets the point 11-6 good
decision
by the titans not to play that ball
it is now 11 to 7.
keira jackson serving it
rogers blocked at the net by the titans
rogers again
and the titans answer with a kill by the
funny thing
is you guys wouldn't know this you'd
think that's the defense's fault and
it kind of is but the block was late
like see how she's not even see how
she's swinging this girl isn't even up
doing a good job up there the 5-9 senior
from deer creek
mackinac high school sends it home
titans back up by five rogers
set up nicely by block
dig by shriver
and we got a whistle and what do we got
double hit
again still want to skip to where i come
back
that the titans averaging a little over
13 kills guys i
swear this year some i don't want to
like make it all about me
but when i was out
we would start to lose like you could
literally see it
and now if mel was out too that was like
our worst rotation
rayna emery continuing to serve to the
back lundine yes
she was beautiful she was the best
blue jays trailing by seven
amy shriver the libero serving and that
kill is gonna be good
by manny williams that might have been
me actually
with 187 coming into
tonight titans with a lot of firepower
up front
that's just a good a lot of height as
well they've got several young ladies
over six feet tall
salinas having a better bj's can't
handle that one another point for the
titans to make it 19-10
biggest lead of this first set for
illinois wesleyan
caitlyn meyer with the jump sir watch
meyers setting it up get back in get
back in the blue jays on the attack
that one is hit by hannah davis she's
saying it was partially blocked
if the officials are saying otherwise
yeah you see that touch
let's take another look at it hard to
tell at that angle
it literally was guys i'm not someone
that's like a sore loser
if i if if they didn't touch it they
didn't touch it
gets the point from the officials to
make it 20 to 10
and and julie hall calling yet another
time out here
20 to 10 we are in the first set this
was my livelihood for so long
we are glad you are logged on to
bluejaytv.com
that's they beat wheaton here in three
sets
and they beat augustana on the road in
rock island in
five sets so some tough
matches in cci yeah that the blue jays
have won
a couple going five sets blue jays
couldn't handle that one and
illinois wesleyan now total control of
his first set
taking another look tipped in the front
row and
went backwards and nobody was home 21
to 10 titans with the lead
yeah yeah she was going to be honest
she was just young taylor
there's nercy and zerleen getting the
kill partially blocked at the net by
illinois wesleyan
the lead is down to 10 now for the blue
jays 21-11 rachel
shooty serving
one-handed diving effort but for nod
the nice effort there by uh celine
uscella
the junior defensive specialist out of
downers grove north
makes it 22 to 11. it was late with the
lead
three points away yeah for wesleyan for
taking the first set
damn i thought i was going to kill that
to the far side kill block now it's the
blue jays on the edge yeah
i kill it
need a few more of those that killed by
hannah davis you see it there
and the blue jays are within 10. 22.
this makes you want to play 12.
taylor zerling the freshman serving
again we're in the first set
best of five blocked
and just pushing it over with her left
hand taylor nerchy
beautifully done good peripheral vision
saw the opening
as you see the little dink effort there
gets the point
22-13
setting it up here to the nearest good
ground
by shootie getting the dig in the back
row
rogers getting it over
yeah to the far side and the dink in
town
she barely got that up hold up
she had 58 blocks coming into tonight
gets credit for one there
and it's now 22 to 14.
blue jays trying to make a game with it
although that's a service error
way too strong so it's now 23-14
and now serving for wesleyan rachel
berkman the junior out of
lincoln way north of course lincolnway
north closed its doors
a while ago and that's a double hit
against the blue jays so a point
for illinois wesley a 10-point lead
and now here is set point
allie rogers with a cross-court kill
hitting the net
was one of the titans okay now
it's gonna be a point for elmer's do you
see the tail
underneath it right there so it's 24-15
i don't know the blue jays trailing by
nine
do i kill it hannah davis with the jump
serve
oh the decaf are beautifully done that
time by
maddie williams and that gives illinois
wesleyan
the first yeah you see how far back she
was when they hit that
like uh i'm not even gonna replay it but
she was way too far back
okay
and welcome back to ra faginal hall we
thank you so much for logging on to
bluejtv.com my name is mark kruger
and we are about ready to get the second
set underway if you've just logged on
illinois wesleyan took the first set by
a score of 25.
i had like the best when my serve was
inconsistent
that was my problem but when i went in
it was literally the best serve on the
team
it was fairly close at the start of the
set as a matter of fact there was only a
three-point lead
for illinois wesleyan it was 10 to 7.
but then the titans closed out on a 15-8
run and they won the first set 25-15
again second place in the cciw
at stake here tonight both of these two
teams five and two
carthage is also five and two carthage
is playing
at one and six wheaton tonight
so the blue jays start with a serve to
get the
second set underway and it's going to
start with a illinois wesleyan point
you see from the back row rachel bergman
hitting it right in the middle of that
funny thing
that should have been the girl in middle
backs because you're supposed to go like
straight just like the first set
illinois wesleyan scores the first point
of the second set strong yeah
and that one is a kill for the blue jays
the tie the second
set up at one
serving now for elmer's get a good look
at taylor nerchy
taylor a senior out of lincoln way east
oh good up ally her griffins
are one of the top ranked teams in high
school football
in the state of illinois a diving effort
by
the libero
oh no not the internet halloween night
let's take another look at the tail end
there
some people are dressed in costume and
the latest
one was scooby-doo coming in
to witness this cciw match very nicely
done
and uh nicely done that time as well was
rachel burkman but
it went out of bounds so the blue jays
there you take a look at the effort by
berkman goes wide to the right and so
the blue jays now with a two-point lead
to the far side goes
the titans tyler brown
with the yeah see mel was a baller oh my
god she was a baller
i say why she's not dead but we don't
play their biggest lead
it was so fun i'm telling you killing it
with my best friend
right below us so serving
is amy shriver shriver the all-time
leader in diggs here at elmhurst college
what a career she has had and that
killed it by tyler brown
the 5-8 junior answering take another
look at it here brown
elevating echoes partially blocked at
the net
six to four blue jays by
two brown going with the finesse serve
now yeah
d blocked by the two good up amy
amy was good too
partially blocked and it went out of
bounds give the kill the block
blocking only five nine but she's got
some hops
take a look at it right there you saw it
partially blocked
and now the titans are within one and
now a chance to tie
the second set up oh blocked beautifully
at the bed
looked like heidi digg
he's gonna get credit for that one
heidi dagg
great job at the net to tie or to kill
and there's a point
and they get the lead back seven to six
blue jays
deflected out of bounds by the titans
seven to six elmer's
rachel shooty the freshman out of
naperville
serving
good effort by block to keep it alive
here's another look at it you see nerchy
and hannah davis but
damn it went out of bounds can't win we
are
fifth tie of this second set
the freshman zerlin pushes it over
oh beautiful dig in the back by shriver
titans back on the attack blocked by the
blue jays and now getting it over is
shooting
a good game setting it up here to block
she goes down the baseline yeah take
that
nicely down by kylie block here's
another look at it here
cross court set and
block actually touched the net so it's a
net violation
and the blue jays get the point
so elmer's with the lead back cerleen
gets the service ace
and the blue jays back up by two
taylor zerleen with 43 service aces
she's the leader
boy only a freshman block yes
boy block i can't deny it that girl was
good
i'm pretty sure she was like the coach's
daughter on the other team outstanding
in the first
two sets so far for illinois wesley to
see her elevate
goes down the baseline for the kill
she's done that a couple times here
tonight
titans are within one we're in the
second set illinois wesleyan won the
first set
25 yeah yeah
yeah so the 6-1 senior from marion
central catholic
gives the blue jays a two-point lead and
now hannah will serve
let's see
of course hannah did that wonderful
rendition of the national anthem
she gets tied up there yeah i can't pass
illinois wesleyan getting the point 10-9
now in favor of the titans block
to serve a chance to tie the second set
up
it's the best of five wesleyan leading
one set to nothing should i skip when
i'm not in i think i'm going to
i know why you guys are here
let's see
i'm not in
goes out so the titans get that point
and the lead is now four hannah davis
trying to go down the near baseline here
we go then we go down a second
i should say blue jays trail the titans
in this second set
no my internet is so trash
52 13.
blue jays just called the timeout
now we're ready to go and that one stays
in
and so that's going to be a service ace
boy that was close but
it was the right call let's take another
look at it here
well very very close
oh they're saying it was out no well
hold on now it's 15 to 14. that score
changed from after the timeout
all right now they got it back to 15
well the scoreboard says 15.
now they're changing the 13.
now they got it right they gave the
point to
elmhurst instead of to wesley now a
point to elmhurst
lundin's kill and hellhurst is trailing
by
two against 14.
so now we got the score all straight
titans on the attack
oh that was my fault oh that was my
fault
so what it is now you guys see how late
i was oh poor amy
i'm sorry saw the tail end of it there
brown really put up the uh
effort into that one
nercy getting it over zerleen now it's
wesley
nice play by nerchy
from the back row getting it over are
the blue jays here's block
cross court kill beautiful dig by
shriver
the freshman zarlene with the kill
attempt
here's dang they had good defense
[Music]
wesleyan answered that one and then
killed by hannah davis
goes out so the titans get that point
damn
we did all that work just for me to head
down down the near baseline
hannah but it went out of bounds so it
is now 18-14
titans by four lanine again blocked by
wesleyan did it go out yes
so the blue jays get the point 18
to 15. right there the official had a
great look at it
well they haven't given the point yet to
the blue jays should be okay now they do
it's 18 to 50.
and a service ace they're coming down
blue jays to within two
i wonder if he won this song take
another look at it the jump served by
rachel
shooty see if rachel can get another one
here
nope
shriver setting it up zerlin
zerlin again yes so taylor cerleen gets
the kill the freshman brings the blue
jays to within one
another look at it here great great job
by zerlin only a freshman
and the blue jays are within one
18 to 17 titans oh and
not handling it at the back celine
all right you guys see like how i'm late
here yeah
i guessed wrong a lot of velocities at
once
in the background basically not much
celine can do about that one
good effort wesleyan
back up by two
yeah illinois wesleyan or
by elmer's i should say hannah davis
this is what i tell you when i get in
the game we close the score
we just did it that was how it works are
within one as we approach
crunch time here in the second set
zerlene serving chance for the blue jays
to tie it up
block
rogers hits the top of the net but goes
out of bounds
boy that was a tough tough
play by rogers beautifully done she's
going for that cross-court kill you saw
it just
trickle off the top of the net and go
out of bounds
two-point lead for the titans
kyra jackson serving rogers that was
it looked like it was partially blocked
but they're saying it was not
see if we could yeah i don't i don't i
think that's a good call
21-18 okay let's get off the bat
three-point lead for the titans and
again elmer's calling attack
i wonder if we won the set
night happy halloween by the way
to everyone out there
so continuing to serve as kyra jackson
the sophomore
out of forsyth illinois
the yeah 21-19
blue jays are within two take another
look at it here hannah really geared up
a lot of momentum going into that one
and now hannah's gonna serve
blue jays trailing by just two nice
block
and that kill is going to be uh oh we
got the point
ally scoured she was set up by taylor
nerchy
tail end of that one 21-20 they touched
it illinois wesleyan with the lead
hannah davis with the jump sir
i'm telling you i loved serving sold out
under
taking a look at it here that tied up
block
and a timeout taken by kim nelson brown
and illinois wesleyan they would always
just tell their players to hit at me
during timeouts
24 wait i skipped too far
not bad so hannah davis continuing to
serve blue jays now with a chance to
take the lead here
okay in the second set block
partially blocked by the blue jays oh
but they're saying
it was a violation against wesleyan so
it's a one-point lead
here for elmer i don't know why i feel
like i missed it
davis continuing to serve too strong
that ties the game up my coaches would
never be mad at me though
maybe they should have been but i served
aggressive that meant it goes out
sometimes
aces sometimes ties the game up at 22. i
still tied up the game
i'm not even mad again wesleyan
won the first set 25-15
block with a nice serve
rodgers tried to push it across
court but it falls into the net
a girl would always pout if she didn't
get six rotations and then just like not
play
and i'm pretty sure this was one of
those days it makes it 23
20. there's so much drama behind the
scenes of a team two
wesleyan with the lead
big point right here for the blue jays
oh croc going down the sideline here's
tyler brown
and she gets the kill as that ball stays
in
24-22
telling you guys set point here for
wesley and they try to take a
commanding two set to nothing lead in
this match
rogers dig by block
and we got a whistle and a violation
against illinois wesley a double hit
and so that ties this second set up
at 24.
so again you have to win by two
yeah and now we're tied at 24.
on that service she's a great serve
taylor nerchy now there you see it i
feel bad for that girl she was actually
a really good volleyball player but she
was like
always sick she was like
24 timeout taken again you have to win
by two and
again you have to win by two
the second set is tied up at 24.
nercy gets it over
to the far side rogers blocked
[Music]
setting up rogers again she pushes it to
the back row
now the titans have the attack yeah amy
found with the attempted kill rogers for
the back row boy what a
what a point we got going here yeah
jays by one so smart
um here's another great effort at the
tail end there
all right last point blue jays kill it
taylor
this is set point
[Music]
[Applause]
if you guys want to watch the full game
um this is the
this is the caption and it's from
elmhurst university
um i have to go but yeah thanks for
watching if you're still here
um reliving my glory days means a lot do
not forget to subscribe to the channel
bring that notification bell
and i will talk to you guys next